well the earth is certainly gone through
a lot of hot times and cold times back
and forth and forth and back and what I
do is I study deep time by looking at
co2 levels and relative temperatures and
we are coming out of a cold time and
moving into a hot time however for this
material particular time in history we
should be moving back in a cold time if
we take the entire ice ages the last two
and a half million years we've been in a
10,000 year column of warmth and it's
time to go cold again and yet doesn't
seem to be in our cards because of all
the carbon dioxide we have put into the
system and in fact we are now at levels
that the world is not seen for the last
40 million years and we will soon be a
carbon dioxide levels that were a
hundred million years ago when we had a
true hothouse world so the game has been
changed
our Antarctic work is to look at the
nature of global temperatures at the end
of the Cretaceous period the Cretaceous
ended 65 million years ago the putative
and and I do believe this is that a
large asteroid hit us in the Yucatan
Peninsula causing the mass extinction
but we're trying to see what happened
and say the 10 million years prior to
that because we know at that time there
was a gigantic volcanic event in India
these are big flood basalts are cold
it's not a single point source volcano
but imagine enormous areas of the earth
creeping lava coming out of cracks and
flowing slowly all around scaring
dinosaurs to death probably run in front
of the stuff probably killed a few
dinosaurs but what it did do is it vent
an enormous quantity of volcanic carbon
dioxide and other gases into the
atmosphere now we wanted to know was
there any precursor to the impact was
the impact just a coup de Gras coming on
an already affected world and it does
seem to be that and the best place to
look at this the best place to
understand anything about global warming
isn't at the tropics that's where
temperatures change the least but it's
at the poles where you have the greatest
absolute change and so we found a 10
degree centigrade change from colder to
warmer in the last two or three million
years prior to the impact itself the
place really did warm up and fast from a
lot of co2 into the atmosphere now
there's obviously parallels to what's
going on in the world today
yeah we are trying to understand past
temperatures and you can do this in a
couple of direct and indirect ways but
the most direct way is to take the
shells if it's an unaltered the original
shell of some of the mosques they live
at that time the ones we look at a
relative to the chambered nautilus
called ammonites beautiful pearly shell
and just run an isotope check on it you
can do this very simply by crushing it
up turn it into a powder and heating
that you get oxygen being driven off you
compare the isotopes it's been known for
50 years that a comparison of the oxygen
isotope 18 which is heavier to the far
more normal oxygen 16 is a direct way of
measuring ancient temperatures so all we
try to do is understand see what
happened to ocean temperatures across
this 2 or 3 million year interval so we
collect the specimens we take them back
to our labs in America we run them
through the machines it came up with the
temperature curve so you have a direct
measurement now say the last 5 million
years of the Cretaceous and its
temperatures in the Arctic and Antarctic
and sure enough those are the places
that should warm up the most if you had
a global warming scenario and in fact
that's exactly what happened
well the differences are just simply
what is causing it I mean in the past
those volcanoes and today's Volvo's or
any other car you want to say but in
reality it's not even the cars and see
this is a misnomer that I see we think
of all those cars and all the exhaust
from them and surely that is a problem
but it's the power plants that make the
steel that make the cars that's the
problem power plants with a big problem
in this planet and that's why we really
have to think seriously about China with
its billion or more people of which one
in a hundred has a personal car America
has 300 million people and over 300
million cars now what happens if the
world has to build a billion cars just
for the Chinese that's a lot of carbon
dioxide still to go to the atmosphere a
lot of power plants and the power plants
in China are almost invariably fueled by
coal and coal was the single worst
polluter that humans could use